well johnny depp won 10 million dollars
in his defamation trial with ex-wife
amber heard he spent a large chunk of it
celebrating with a curry in birmingham
reportedly racking up an incredible bill
of fifty thousand pounds i'm joined now
by the owner of nasi restaurant mohammed
hussain
well good evening to you you must be you
don't look that cheerful but if johnny
depp had dropped 50 grand in my
restaurant i'd be thrilled
hi good evening ps morgan uh yeah we're
very excited to have johnny depp in our
restaurant um but there are a lot of
rumors going around at the moment in
respect to how much he actually spent in
the restaurant
um and his unconfirmed amount because we
haven't actually disclosed anything
as of yet
but you i understand i caught a long
chat with with johnny depp but mainly
about his movie career is that right
we were just discussing his day-to-day
life at the moment and how he's enjoying
birmingham what he likes to eat
and we were just delighted to have him
in our restaurant in birmingham city
center
it's quite unheard of to have an
a-lister being around
especially on broad street in birmingham
and i understand you've got three
daughters who are massive fans of johnny
depp
and he he did some one-liners for them
is that right from his pirates of the
caribbean and child in the chocolate
factory
yes i had the privilege of uh inviting
my daughters uh to be present while he
was here
and uh one of the things that they
really requested from him was to do some
one-liners from the
charlie and the chocolate factory a
movie that he did and he did that for
them and they were they were over the
moon about it
i i mean i'd imagine he was in
celebratory mood i know he didn't
discuss the the case with him but what
kind of guy is johnny depp i've never
met him you've had the chance to spend
this extraordinary night with him in
your restaurant what was he like
he's a very chilled out guy
he spoke to everybody here i had friends
i had families who were in the
restaurant
and he made his he made an effort to
speak to
every one of them he hugged them he
kissed them and he was very
accommodating to everybody's requests
he spent a lot of time with me
personally in my office
and he just sat in there and he just
spoke to me one to one and it was a
really nice experience in itself
when you got the call from depth
security team to make the booking for
the whole place presumably you then had
to let down some other customers how did
you do that
we had our ways of ensuring that we
didn't upset any of our guests and we
could accommodate his request the
restaurant is very large so
even when he did come in here there
might have been a few people here but by
the time he started eating everybody had
left
well mohammed and it's not often is it
that you get a hollywood superstar comes
in and bugs the whole place out i
understand you did more business from
that one night than you normally do with
400 diners so i'd imagine you would like
to say a heartfelt thank you to mr depp
and his team
yes of course
any restaurant that
can generate that sort of income on on
any given night
it is is a large amount of money to be
spent for while somebody's dining with
you
well congratulations it was a a great
bit of fun we really appreciate it
mohamed i'm saying thank you very much
for tonight